I was a polyam before
Marcus and I got married.
You two are married?
(intense upbeat guitar music)
(laughs) Not in your traditional
heteronormative sense.
We're married spiritually, and sexually.
Yeah but not literally (laughs).
That's great.
Nadia's been saying that
romantic comedies are bad.
Wow, you're quite beguiling, aren't you?
(gasps) What's going on?
Are you kidding me?
Have you seen Notting Hill?
Have you seen 13 Going on 30?
My life's become a mother--
(truck beeping)
Romantic comedy!
Boom boom boom boom boom yeah!
I think I just, I need
to lie down (laughs).
I'll be totally fine then.
(slamming)
(crashing)
(groaning)
(slamming)
Yeah I'm gonna cry myself
to sleep every night.
[Boy On Left In Car] Me too.
[Boy On Right In Car]
When I'm out partying.
Go to school boys.
This guy's either gonna think,
here's another kid with a fake ID
or here's McLovin, the 25
year old Hawaiian organ donor.
Makes me feel young again.
(punch landing)
(slamming)
I just wanna go to the
rooftops and scream,
I love my best friend Evan!
Engage!
(clicking)
That sounds like a lot of fun.
(vomiting)
(screaming)
I wanna apologize.
I'm not even confident of
which end that came out of.
Will you be my maid of honor?
Of course I will.
[Brunette Woman In Blue
Shirt] Let's go meet the rest
of the bridal party.
You're so pretty (laughs).
(laughs) You're so cute.
(laughing)
Did you come from work?
(liquid running)
What are we doing for
the bachelorette party?
(clinking)
Female fight club.
We grease up, beat the crap out of her.
(punch landing)
(yelling)
But mine wore off, so what's up.
This weekend we gonna need
a little less mom Lisa
and a little more freaknik Lisa.
Don't let me go.
Don't let me go!
(excited cheering)
Come on now, you a fierce sexual goddess.
I'm a bad bitch goddess.
Oh!
[Woman In Red Jumpsuit] Yes,
now go out there and slay.
Hi there!
Scott Delacorte.
Elizabeth Halsey.
I'm the new sub.
I love how his eyes
sparkle when he smiles.
Ooh.
You wanna like grab a bite sometime?
You still a gym teacher?
I am, yeah.
Suck it.
Awesome, this went great,
all right (pops lips).
Don't throw at her, throw through her.
(children cheering)
(smacking)
Things are about to change around here.
Recess is over.
Me and the other students, we kinda,
we've come up with a plan.
I think you should just
share with the class
some details about your project.
You know I would, but
(laughs) my contract with NASA
prohibits me from saying anything.
If we were ever to say anything,
we would (mimics choking).
Dead, killed in our sleep.
And who would want that?
Not me.
Oh this is bad, this is really bad.
Should we call 911?
(car revving)
(yelling)
(slamming)
Boom.
(gun firing)
(yelling)
It's just like death in the library.
What happens in death a library?
They died, that's why it's
called death in the library.
(gun firing)
(yelling)
(smashing)
- [Soldiers] Run away, run away!
(chaotic yelling)
(roaring)
If you will not show us the grail,
we shall take your castle by force.
You don't threaten us English pig dogs.
(bouncing)
(mooing)
(crashing)
(yelling)
- [Man Wearing Fur]
All this will be yours.
(metal clanking)
(groaning)
(slamming)
All that you can see,
stretched out over the hills
and valleys of this land.
That'll be your kingdom.
(explosion blasting)
Yes, I see myself as
something of a shepherd
guiding our family
through life's passages.
(loud smooching)
When my sheep wander, I use my prod
to keep my flock in line.
Oh there are a lot of family dynamics
at play here (laughs).
Everything okay Greg?
Everything's great.
There's the superstar.
Hey, hi, oh.
Louis what are you doing?
Is this the book?
What is, no, come on!
- [Louis] Putting that back, right?
I got 'em.
One of the reasons I
wanted to come here tonight
was to discuss our future.
Of course.
I think we should break up.
(high pitched squealing)
I'm seriously in love with you.
I love you.
Liar!
(crashing)
Going to Harvard is the only way
I'm going to get the love of my life back.
I go here!
You got into Harvard Law?
What, like it's hard?
(coughing)
(choking)
With test scores like these,
you can roll up any joints you want,
but Harvard, gentlemen,
is not just any joint.
It's an institution.
Music, artists, and the women.
Mm (imitates smooching).
What's your name?
I'm Jamal, got weed?
- [Woman] You ain't my type.
Them girls only know three words.
Stop, no, and don't.
- [Both] Next!
I think I can make out our little
friend right there.
(water splashing)
- [Man In Scrubs] Stop it!
Ooh, shabbat shalom,
somebody's circumcised.
Okay, you'll never get any
sympathy out of us for this.
She's going crazy.
Julia, I'm not gonna sleep with you.
(smacking)
We'll see about that.
(gasping)
Got the cheese?
- [Man In Plaid] What
kinda cheese you thinking?
What is that, three hits?
Yeah.
30 large.
If you kill two, could
we get the third one
hold the cheese?
(fireworks blasting)
(cheering)
- [Announcer] Ladies and gentlemen,
from Los Angeles,
Motley Crew.
Look where we are.
We got an old man, a kid drummer,
a cover band singer and runaway.
No one would've thought we'd make it here,
so win it all or lose it all,
we're Motley Crew.
Oh my god, those are my pants.
They look so much better on me.
I'm just a hopeless romantic dude.
All love all the time.
Tommy.
Heather.
(laughs) The Fall Guy, I love that show.
The Fall Guy's Heather Thomas.
I'm Heather Locklear.
You're mean.
I guess you're the air conditioning guy?
Yeah, hi Sasha, hi, hello, hi.
Those good looking guys,
those white dudes with the beard.
They come up to you on the street,
all good looking.
Now I know what it feels like
to be completely starstruck.
The only stars that matter
are the ones you look
at when you dream.
(sobs) Thank you.
(air whooshing)
♪ Hey ♪